hello friends family strangers in the
darkroom who found us on the Internet
welcome to another episode of impaired I
am JC cariah's and I am slightly damp
with excitement for this episode hi I'm
Chris cope I'm high on life we're the
co-host of this fantastic adventure into
debauchery I'm an alcoholic
chris is a pothead we're gonna have some
friends on we're gonna play games we're
gonna get [ __ ] up and have a good time
why don't you guys stick around and
watch us do that this ginger had a tree
instead six foot five inches tall
hailing from a sleepy town of
Warrenville Illinois you've seen him on
Comedy Central this is not happening and
show times comedy from South by South
but he's the first ginger we've had on
the show and probably the last give it
up for TIA
a statue last bye-bye you see her on the
new Netflix show coming on and The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert she's from the
city of Stars Los Angeles California
please welcome
[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
impaired welcome our guest John hi give
it up and Heather give it up guys the
show thanks for does er you I was kind
of an ego trip because someone's
spinning in thank you feel good yeah one
of the things we like to jump in right
away is we have a secret word that if
any of us says it you're gonna hear this
so that means that you've said the
secret word and then everyone would
drink smoke or whatever whatever your
whatever your inner poison but cheers
guys this episode I am dual wielding my
foot and alcohol had a rough day and
we've really stepped it up we have a new
sponsors or their straws for drinking
and now we have them in our cups which
is fun Chris you want to jump off into
the first new game
okay wait this is the first time we've
actually done this unimpaired and I'm
excited I am excited to do this
basically the game is called what's in
the box what's in the box it's you know
yeah but at the end of seven like the
end of seven that's exactly it we have a
mystery box and inside it mystery
contents Shawn Heather are gonna put
their hand in there and gonna feel the
run they're gonna have a 15-20 seconds
I'm sorry I'm gonna keep whatever did
you guys are good whatever's in there in
there Jon check over there is nothing
living harmful or anything like that in
here just no I feel like I'm on cops
like are there any needles so stick your
hand in and then you got about 20
seconds well while you're giving us a
long long time
we ask for the awesome this feeling you
know watch feel it you know how to fill
up your hang with your hands and your
tips like use your mind to interpret
with the hand feel sensory all right you
got an ID of one of this John this box
was made by our arts and crafts
department Chris cope house to do
research he's our research and
development and our arts and crafts he's
really he's John you're giving that a
real good feel huh you gave college less
of a try yeah no okay John you think I
don't know what it is would you like yes
yeah cuz John's jugs look I don't say
it's either some kind of it's like a
like water bottle or flashlights sorts
okay well my my first guess would be
first this is gonna be honey like a
thing of honey uh-huh but now it's I
think because of what I'm picking up
some context clues I'm thinking maybe
it's a flashlight that's correct
it is the first woman you've ever had
you're not you're the second it is a
Vulcan vibration way vagina pocket
vagina
did I win it no I gotta take this back
your return to his house Christmas I did
no no it's sealed yeah because I
couldn't get a finger well in the middle
of itself actually wasn't too far off
he's really good guess what he said
flower you said Visor I think we figured
it out cuz I couldn't I was like I have
never liked I thought the flesh like the
actual fleshly no I've never seen a
flashlight and it's not seen now you've
seen you hold it up flashlight no it's
got a handle that doesn't have a handle
so that's why I was like I think it's
cuz Chris spend as little money as
possible on it I don't know that's
probably a good one honestly every one
of them was about twenty dollars and
that was the best that was the only one
that vibe
for 20 bucks did you look on Yelp for
any reviews I like that it's called the
Vulcan it's like a pop you want you
wanna [ __ ] this machine instead of a
shocker it's yeah it would be great if
fill all those like had like a different
Star Trek character on them it's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] it sag live long and come
to McDonald's yes have no idea how much
joy that brought me that's the best use
of a flashlight I've ever seen the
laid-back version of it the best song
missing flashlight is not the secret
word I don't think that they had any
idea that we were gonna be doing they're
sticking again oh yeah that's not the
secret word no no okay you know so
secret words been harder and harder for
us to guess what happens is is that we
usually get it very late in the episode
it'll happen by happenstance gosh that
was a repetitive way to say that good
job Jay see where it happens dancin
that's what counts for it so it's a
pretty big fail happening happens pretty
terrible live a band like a ska band
you'd walk out of it they came on good
Oh God happenstance is opening for a
Coldplay again but it happens you know
what he's good but he's not great it's
not Hootie the Blowfish will jump into
the another game guys gonna play two
truths and a lie that's what we're doing
that all right okay yeah you feel good
Johnnie oh I would rather he just got
excited I saw the looks not exciting I
just like you know Jon gets excited for
dishonesty I'm nervous that I'm not
gonna be good at it I'm not a good I'm
not a good liar I know it sounds stupid
okay no no but that's that's that's a
good thing to know so if the thing that
the things that sound forced really are
forced because some people have been
very good at lying
yeah you've had some sociopaths on this
absolutely you know what it's because of
what the one is about yeah well we're
not the first comics that have been on
correct yeah absolutely not it's been
also on comics absolutely have comic
song cuz they know how to get [ __ ] up
during the day and everyone knows the
way they get something in no house they
don't have
no that'll be like work I can pencil
that in and tell my wife I'm working
it's like what you'd be out there but
you have an excuse yeah like you're at a
show good comedy I was making the joke
in the afternoon psycho I mean look it's
gonna be on my reel it looks good how
much minute castigate what are you doing
what what are you doing in the real I'm
a heading like a bar but it's like I'm
treats like a future mom it's like it's
like a bomb jumping dots a bomb is a
future bong the only ice cream in the
future it hit with machines take over
its do this who's got me ripped how can
I go first actually yeah but hit it off
okay all right you guys ready yeah
perfect
what is it oh yeah you don't know I have
one yeah that way of course we don't
[ __ ] know I'm sensing a lot of
tension oh yeah no no we did have them
truly hate each other that's not true
it's like a lot of love okay yes ready
okay my favorite baseball team is in New
York Yankees I have won ten grand on a
game show and what what's the third one
somebody hates art hey that's enough my
hair that's where appropriate and your
third one was my third one was my my my
favorite movie is godfather okay do we
call those do we tell what with the
window okay so the first one was the New
York Yankees his favorite baseball team
it's not true you should know you're
basically his wife that's true I have a
better idea of what the answer is
oh yeah that's not true right
that's the again I would I would also
vote against the Yankees answer the the
$10,000 the reason I laughed is because
Chris has used that on
show a total of three times every time
he says people know I got paid he took
so long to come up with the last one he
kind of like stuttered a little before
he said it was the Godfather movie I
think it probably is this favorite movie
but maybe not funny it's not and he's a
comedian but he is a crazy person I know
my I know I think I know the answer you
know the answer what would you I would
say that the Yankees are not your
favorite baseball team what you said
I'll go with Godfather okay no and I and
I and I will just say the answer his
favorite baseball team is at the event
it's the Atlanta Braves first place
[ __ ] liar liar Chris I did win money
on a game show I love The Godfather what
game show wasn't yes oh yeah he's
brought it up three times brightly sorry
I haven't watched every episode
no but he's brought up he's brought in
three drives crazy [ __ ] lazy with his
[ __ ] life oh it's not I mean that's
the truth no that's you know his lie was
kind of bad it was a bad way did you
just think of it what's the worst team I
could pick you didn't even pick like a
southern team I said the Rays or
something oh yeah what about a better
life Marlon's yeah that's true that's
that's like yeah you could be from
anywhere and be a bandwagon all right
all right Heather here we go okay I was
the treasurer of my high school okay I
used to work in real estate all right
and I was a Girl Scout until I was 14
I see I like that the details on the
last one is the one that made me go like
she added more information on the last
one I was a Girl Scout until eighteen
but that could also be that's part of
the weirdness of it I think right what
do what do you think what three things
just make me sound super square Thank
You sock someone who's like sort of like
spent time trying to figure out that
they are running for office after I hit
this baby bottom in the future and the
candidate of the future
let me count your money as treasurer
yeah you know what money the money
experience that will help with the
candor some reason the treasurer one is
the one I think is the lie that's the
one you're going yeah that's what I'm
going with - I mean the real estate one
sounds like a lie but everybody could
have done like anybody could you know
like [ __ ] how that's not what I meant
I just mean like it's as if you're if
you want to be a good side huh laughs
our bags
oh okay not fall back outside hustle got
it sell houses while you swagger you got
a lot of successful Realtors I don't
know what this flip houses you got wait
talk to John he'll my flip cars houses
I'm gonna say treasurer
I'm gonna go I'm going I'm going with
the Girl Scout until 14 that's
interesting you're gonna be like a Girl
Scout until I was yes webinar 12 that's
I'm 14 oh [ __ ] oh oh oh my god uh guys
turn the cameras off right now he also
same one I feel like I've never been
right with one except for when it's
Chris cuz I know all of his lies yeah
you guys know each other it must be hard
for you do you ever cuz a long time as
you guys are just that plain connect us
feel better
what's that like pretty much okay I have
one testicle I come in strong hit on a
woman who did not speak my language
while I wasn't wearing pants oh they're
all good one
and when I was a little kid me and my
best friend saved a kid from drowning in
the public pool who turned out to be an
Olympian like later on like not an
Olympic swimmer right but another no
idea whoa whoa okay so strong out the
gate I have I just almost all three of
those came together last second cuz I've
been like really nervous about that poll
you got to come up with these days I'm
like if he's been lying about the
testicle he is a monster and I kind of
like it
how is he a mom I mean I guess yes I
mean to all the two if they got one ball
out there it's not fair - yeah that's
not true I think it's hilarious sorry
all one ball you people think testicles
are funny it doesn't matter if I said
one or none you have one real testicle
you have a chump John the second one
again what's it on a woman who didn't
speak English well I believe that one
yeah that one there's no Chris honestly
I was always standing next to him on the
street when he said that like not really
but I was picturing in my mind like John
just dick out like violence but also
amazing men are idiot but we'll hit on
anybody it'll be rescuing rescuing
another kid at a pool
maybe that's why that one's pretty good
I don't know I don't know I think I'm
going testicle testicle I've known you
long enough you were to tell me you had
one ball I think it's a lie testicle
it's an testicle as well well then all
of us can't take the ball I'm gonna go
with you uh oh god I'm gonna I'm gonna
say you're a liar about being a hero
that's the worst one Wow
I had cancer when I was 19 and they had
to remove my right testicle that is true
one ball actually in my Instagram bio
particular cancer survivor wrong and
then I did hit on a woman while I was
not wearing pants oh it was in Germany
and I never know I'm glad that anyone
had to think about
I said meeting my best friend like just
me was like I said we should do
something I was like I guess if you're
gonna I have to when you hit on the
woman did you say like have you ever
seen one ball no actually what happened
was I she like started laughing cuz I
wasn't I kind of came around the corner
on her and there she was with a bunch of
their dudes and I wasn't she saw that I
was like naked from the waist down she
started laughing with all her friends
and I was like then she said started
talking to me in broken English and as
soon as she started talking to me I like
leaned against the baha'i like that's
how a male mind like I was like oh I'm
in 19 20 years old I was like oh yeah
anguish not parently is running around
like yeah not was there actually wasn't
that was actually 22 probably I was
there travelling with some friends we
were well it's Oktoberfest and that's
what happened it's like you got blackout
drunk enough how'd you lose your pants
I've just [ __ ] in an alley and then
blacked out again and it's all I'm not
you can see it and this is not happening
yeah when he told that was in my mind I
was like I felt like I heard some of
that story before yeah that's good did I
sound it like a good like I sounded
honest on all I love the heat real into
thinking he was a hero except for me
you're like I saw when I was 10 years
old
I fell out of a second-floor balcony
fell from it for sure football and I
injured my neck and if the injury would
have gone a little bit further I would
have been paralyzed waist-down for sure
and I have never had anal sex
you've never been [ __ ] up oh I think
he's had anal sex and he wants everyone
to know I'm gonna go with the third I
gotta be I'm with you I think the other
one like you're lying about almost being
paralyzed that's psychotic or you're
lying about what
the first one oh yeah no well that's
offensive to people that fall a lot so
yeah I'm gonna go hunt down your one
testicle crusader I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go with it yeah that wasn't the third
one right which the which is that I've
never had anal sex yeah that's gotta be
him I mean no justice or shortly okay
you're saying that's the lie yeah you've
never you never had you've never told me
about the football thing you falling off
some makes sense
ah the last one anal sex that is your
cup of tea I know that's not your
company okay how am I supposed to know
that it's not like he has a look that
says anal sex I'm not into it
it's just said anything not about us
anything it's like whatever hole you
have what do you got yeah I think it's
the second one he had a football injury
mhm oh man that is a yurt so you're a
bigger dick than me I like a hero you
like no no I did I didn't fall I know I
can I closet second the second I was on
the balcony we were at in Disney World I
was 10 and I climbed out and I dropped
down into the bottom the next floor
you're on the balcony of Disney World
not on purpose I successfully climbed
down you're spider-man yeah spider boy
frame wall super safe guys yeah guys two
doors down he doesn't I told you that
story before someone doesn't listen is
what the answer okay man whatever neck
football chercher [ __ ] almost
couldn't walk alright moving on Coco
Coco not tough to move all about rain
just as hazy what's that thing called
the vape X of Apex
the baby maker from is for me loud
muskers line
Elon Musk is here all right you made a
reservation under Elon Musk us they
would like give you a really nice table
and a super can be like our do you mean
Elon Musk yes I forgot my own name
yeah sorry about that you know the
scientists on the future what's your mr.
Burton musk asleep I don't know mr. musk
us oh that's [ __ ] hilarious now we'll
play another little game I like to it's
it's another brand-new one it's an
interesting moments and intoxication
brought to you by our sponsor we don't
have a sponsor yet you know sign for
that or do we run a commercial no no we
do not gonna read this story see eight
and a half by read from the story here
that Biola pretty cool actually
[Applause]
it's like an uncle trying to tell him
that listen I'm about to say so and you
assume the presidency in 1829 March 21st
they had he had a party a huge party
that's the first thing did 20,000 people
showed up to an inaugural open house the
White House they opened the doors to
these 20,000 people and it got so insane
inside of the White House that Andrew
Jackson had to sneak out a second-floor
window and then until the only way they
could get everyone out of the White
House is they opened up barrels of
whiskey on the lawn of the White House
and brought everybody out nobody likes
to party like slate window now that I'm
looking at it I'm like
I'll be next it's me guy whom you're
gonna put on some money let's see now
again I feel bad when we have Chris does
all of our research and that was usually
sways pretty southern no I mean in terms
of like good guy let's start story the
story was Andrew Jackson's is such a
degenerate that he's like yeah I'll open
the doors to the White House and let
everyone come in right mud on the carpet
later on yeah that's the only way free
with barrels of nothing back in the day
people I mean people I lose a history
class in college like people walk down
the street carrying their own keg yeah
people drink ridiculous amount until
they fell down well I'm doing a walk out
this wasteful
yeah that's why blackout [ __ ]
in his house I was surprised bringing
about some more whiskey didn't black out
Colonel Thomas mansion gifted President
Jackson a 1400 pound wheel of cheese
will change accident [ __ ] they could
they couldn't they had no place to put
it yeah they could it fermented for more
than a year well Jackson put out ads in
the paper who are invited the whole
country to help him eat the cheese
that's what it said in the paper I'm
sure lots of [ __ ] cheese even the
slaves can't eat all this cheese yeah
the last thing I would do is give it to
them come out here white people it needs
cheese there's no game this is just
simply me reading things that happen
we're changing it was supposed to be
interesting moments of ataxia this is
just things Chris found on the internet
oh but that's mean interesting in the
factory we're gonna bring something to
somebody as a housewarming gift or some
[ __ ] 1,400 pounds veal about sheep
how do you even make your a dick if you
bring that to a party that's it every
other shoe rule is your drugs now
see this LSD that I mean seriously
everything was like I took things like
where are all the stories about cheese
what is it what about drinking you know
here's the [ __ ] LSD and [ __ ] the moon
was made of cheese
I had any drugs to know that I know what
the boots made up it's obviously a
celebrated cheese day and more than
10,000 Chris I'm sure added this line
patriotic zeal of you read this [ __ ]
sentence and know he absolutely did not
realize cheese day arrived more than
10,000 patriotic citizens answered their
call of duty ha ha meaning hmm I gotta
take a dump this cheese is really
backing me up why are we eating so much
cheese is there and they finished it in
two hours they ate 1,400 pounds of
cheese and also if there was any doubt
as to whether society was savage back
then they ate in two hours
1400 pounds of cheese and then I don't
know why Chris added this after they ate
the cheese they awarded Jackson when the
carriage made out of Hickory sticks he
leaves in parts which we frankly didn't
even know it's possible
what's a Hickory stick every stick is
wood it's I don't know I'm just reading
off the internet man okay so you did
copy and there's no official research
yeah you do anything but mocks the
research done my [ __ ] on him for it
you're like the guy who copies off the
guy next to you [ __ ] Edie would you
just do your homework already do it
better get to your homework my mom is
good about winds up the dynamic I
I help move things along and Christmas
bad research and they [ __ ] on it my
research is very factual there's what's
next yeah gonna read someone's Twitter
yes I am
it's yours Heather we've got some very
entertaining points guys oh it's gonna
be great ah do that once ooh do it no
yeah we want you to stay really you guys
are and that pee-wee's Playhouse none of
us got it I did it yeah you got it
Heather thank you oh yeah let's jump
into one of our favorite segments it's
called wasting where we're gonna do you
know the food Chris introduce the bud
okay so this week's wasting is called a
Mick Duncan
it's basically disgusting McDonald's
McDouble with a McChicken stuffed inside
enjoy that hand motion was really thank
you
I literally wait after you said that I
smelled a fart like I didn't
[Music]
oh you saw how this monstrosity was
created and now let's pass it out to our
panel here and we're gonna see if if it
looks as delicious as it I think it's
important to tell people right now that
I didn't see how we did not see how was
made so I'm gonna take a bite not
knowing how it was me because this is
the kind of thing that I will eat
without going or understanding
I don't need a mr. Rogers tore through a
sausage factory like a brown paper bag
Oh expand your breast of all cities were
rewrapped they certainly were rear ass
McDonald's a sponsor no not at
McDonald's Oh God
oh well that's okay guys are like
talking about stuffed inside it sounds
like you just looks like it's just a
chicken patty with whatever McDonald's
concludes I just told you that when I
tried it I didn't like it but you just
when you said how it was made I mean it
looks like it was made Chris is not
always bitten into it all right uh yeah
Chris what do you have explain talk talk
it out how do you feel good I'm good
it's crap you know in general this is
the medical online that's not a pickle
there's some moldy cheese on my wait
what do you think of them it's not
terrible I guess a plain burger or
chicken on its own is better you know
what it was because I tried it when we
were sober I don't hate it as much now I
don't kind of like it I'll also say that
if you even remotely like these two
things like it were you liked it if you
do oh boy did they had the problem thank
you if you really like getting drunk
really like smoking pot you can combine
foods all day here open up your sandwich
my wife I don't wanna do that but I'll
do like I would do cheese's Jesus it's
still not my favorite thing that we've
done well if it was you'd be a weirdo
like oh god the one that we other things
there the one that the one that I like
the best is probably even grosser
defeats arena with Pizza reto um what's
not a pizza in a burrito yeah oh it's a
bucket it's a toasty nose pizza okay
first of all it's not pizza its Totino's
mhm it's a thirty nose and then we
filled the inside of it with pizza rolls
pepperoni and mozzarella cheese and then
sealed it up and then what I'll [ __ ]
your pants yeah yeah all together we
shoot our pants right crazy people no I
loved it I thought it'd be delicious
that was my my favorite I'll just still
eat it no no no most of the time
actually we don't finish no one finishes
the food that's ridiculous
no one does alright mmm
if this is really a McDonald's patty I
haven't had one in a very long time
come on guys what the [ __ ] this is gonna
come in and start flipping tip no joke
about our studio at ease they don't give
a [ __ ] one tractor come on in boots like
hey you think we could blackmail them
into sponsoring us well hey I'm positive
my dog is a sponsor than I take back
what I said no wait one sponsor straws
they help me drink straws ruining our
oceans are they anything plastic brother
[ __ ] you straws fog we need a sponsor
man yeah whatever
all right know what just eat the whole
time right yeah they just sit there I go
there's no editing looking that guy
[ __ ] put in his facebook tasty oh
he's definitely taking a jump right now
you do talk about [ __ ] your pants a
lot you talk about what you know what
you know all right
does he give me a ginger oh yeah shut up
let's pair up for a little game that we
like to call like the worst improv class
ever everyone pair off like God why
we're gonna play sorry not any better
than that guys hold on it's not any more
creative than that we brought John hot
gun to make sure that this is the last
one we ever tape we're play another game
with X girl sketchy partners essentially
what it is is weak remote me and Chris
are gonna be blindfold we're gonna be
given an object we're gonna describe
that object to our guests who are gonna
draw what we say they'll be sitting back
to her and we will be facing your team
John and Heather not our team you were
the winners pastor Coco so basically
you're gonna hand me what you're gonna
turn this way yeah yeah we gotta go back
to back and then you guys are given the
key tonight on two fat men blindfolded
Jake in the blunts Sydenham here's next
day to fat blue is that I don't know who
is it
I don't know
I could tell that having breathing's
cope yes thanks for charcoal that's
usually my medium now but sorry we're
doing whatever that you see what else
bowdry whatever the [ __ ] man we gave you
is is the budget so oh yeah you guys
robbed a dry-erase store twice you
wanted your I will not I don't wanna be
hindered
oh my no well then it's really good
Chris you have your objects
I do you have yours I do you guys ready
somebody yeah sure wanted to trade
shirts they do what you guys describing
something I'm touching it first hold on
yeah you're touching I'm giving it a
good touch I'm using my hands to rub a
lawyer if you figured out you guess you
could but the way it's easier to
actually okay yeah I'm just not gonna
talk so don't tell him are you ready
guys yeah I'm rockin the roll
all right heavier I'm gonna go in the
scratchy draw square so drop John draw
to draw square new pens pens so let's do
it vertical on the front top of it
we're there : all right now they're
gonna those pens are gonna connect to
the tank volume knockers I'm the friend
into uh and now yeah now the head like
yeah I'm alongside they're not always
like like a copy a tiny bit we're like
dialed I need I know sure it's the top
of it dinosaur it a tiny dinosaur ah
that's what it is cuz it's gonna on me
and it's an object the left side so
there's a long side that it's not in the
objects object it's got grooves and then
grooves grooves where the dinosaur head
will be yeah you ever describe something
no I have it there if there's a lot of
items
inside of like the teeth area though
it's a cube it's a rectangular it's a 3d
rectangle 3d rectangle draw that yeah
essentially what it is and now that
you've drawn something already
oh yeah real Picasso over perfect it's
like I think I believe the the object
itself is a wrench that you kind of
almost sighs two different shapes but
it's also like it's a crescent wrench
like in one row yeah but no maybe not
don't draw presents go with what I
described top on the small dinosaur head
at the top of my god side take a good
got you right yeah you know ah there are
one to see it for sure still be pretty
good okay
oh my god you could draw like a rub
rubber or never covers for the ass
for the pence they've kind of here I'm
saying the cover is good but like on the
opposite side of the auxilary cords no
around the corner from yeah okay so joy
yet to the rather their base like to
base where it can like it's a that's
anything that's the thank gonna just
that's what it is
so my supposed to describe where there's
no once I figured out like I was trying
to make it harder they should be but I
think we got a better picture out of it
you think you know it is I think we're
still gonna win is what I'm saying I'm
not exactly sure what this is but I have
an idea of what it is are we getting
free free we feel good with our drawings
you maybe we reveal yeah yeah alright
let's really feel like I'm gonna get
some sort of oh holy [ __ ]
yeah but very soon alien dildo hilarious
promote yeah oh my god
let's the artists ample is an amplifier
but yeah that well this is what I drew
from your decision
you said crescent wrench that's also not
a crescent wrench I don't know what a
crescent wrench is okay let's see what
is this what is the first I said is
smoking a joint I said hold on hold on
well hey I say I said two pins that
connect it into the head of a dinosaur
and there you go take a gander everybody
it was a dinosaur head
I don't know when you lived but this is
what I look like back in my day it looks
like a bunny I think we I think we were
you said joint no no no I said there's a
joint I got weird how does it have a
joint there and then that's smoke coming
off the joint drew oh [ __ ] you guys did
really oh my god what is that like an
audio yeah it's not a plug-in a notice
from several levels alien dildo man
that's taking guesses well yeah we got
it
alien I still won for the aliens
pleasure holding hey I've loved with it
did both of these things just come out
of like the back of a pickup truck they
came out of whatever we could find the
red bag damn it this was [ __ ] really
on point I'm gonna give him the
instructions on the Heather's actually
very just helping me out I'm gonna say a
lot of that feather I would say oh
absolutely asking amazing questions yeah
like a lot of the proceeds involved with
Bob you have to all right don't I'm
trying to be [ __ ] nice here no no you
defend your drawing yeah for the rest of
the show go ahead bud that's fine I feel
like that is that supposed to be John
Rambo John Rambo I would I was gonna say
hambone but John hambo like a company
sort of Jon Hamm
oh [ __ ] indeed [ __ ] oh it's time for
BYOB it's the my favorite game 100%
starting from my favorite game bigger oh
the bartender everybody we're gonna get
jumping in to be your own bartender
basis we're gonna get a prompt of a
drink name and then you guys are gonna
try and make your best version of that
guessing what it is we're gonna get a
clue the name and then you're gonna make
an attempt at making the drink what is
it cheating if I've never attended bar
before and don't really mix a lot of
cocktails no it's actually better it's
bright good good 90 seconds oh are you
bartending yeah but like not in years
and I was already okay we've had other
bartenders on here's the fun thing some
people like maybe John if you want well
really go after it and make a make a
wacky one no no I'm gonna go for it I'm
gonna make Chris people inning Chris
keeps winning I'm gonna make my cocktail
Chris keeps waiting all day I feel like
Chris only lost who do you lose - hola
clinician beat Chris and he was a
legitimate bartender dude float in here
with us
and then he [ __ ] one man that he
would tell course he did the guy wins at
everything that let's get that let's get
that cocktail name and our clue I was
just gonna say guys remember sex in the
city and then well I think that that's
the reason why we have these nice
glasses that's weird guys they're us our
clock 90 seconds to make your cocktail
I'm such a Miranda I think I actually
know this one I'm uh I'm one character
from that that I am oh I'm a pallbearer
whoa whoa they are there try to cook
sorry
it's an inside baseball for wrestling
funny
I'm Paul Bearer all right guys I said
the clock but I know that not the kite
burns I mean it's a pretty pretty good
let's get it up all right so clock
readies drive that car go yeah I think
it's [ __ ] June no that'll be a gin
martini right it's not a martini is a
Cosmo right wait what are we doing we're
making more tea suppose you say Cosmo is
not really oh all right well then kind
of follow Heather's lead is it a rum
martini Kristin just having fun over
there it looks like Amy Jones like
having trouble sake huh no I want to mix
it right yeah yeah get in there
yeah I got you crying deep to have it
poured Artie uh he's good by the end of
it hopefully can I get a ginger beer
Chris
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] put that back on
itself alright so let's start with
Heather describe your drinks you made a
real Cosmo
I think it'd make a real concept I like
that it's triple sec vodka cranberry
juice and I garnished it with a lime but
the amounts of things I put in there was
strictly eyeballed I like you know what
got the triple the fact that you use the
term the garnish and eyeball makes this
already better than a lot of what people
let's listen let's give it a stir I
didn't put any garnish it but at pinis
did oh yeah if you feel like a Samantha
or a Carrie holy [ __ ] that's delicious
it's delicious
mm-hmm very good grab that what's the
opposite side of the glass you suck that
like I have herpes I'm just a pallbearer
trying to figure his way out with this
sim back to the wrestling team it people
are like why is he carrying coughing
this is what I like no that's so good
it's so [ __ ] that's really tasty it's
[ __ ] delicious well you know what
they say a man's favorite drink is a
cosmopolitan
I've never yeah Chris on the air
beverage okay here it is
go ahead describe it hold it like yeah
you know Bacardi spiced rum triple
second simple syrup and good Z and a
four really oranges in the drink you
know it's just a very large no get
scurvy I'm taking a sip of it oh god
it's gonna be terrible that means it's
working I drink I honestly am poo it
tastes it tastes like it tastes very bad
yeah I don't know what it's like
robitussin with with grenadine well that
doesn't sound that bad please it's bad
I'm gonna put house like New Orleans
it's very sweet oh thank you
it's garbage but we're not gonna find
out what the ingredients are I thought
like you knew how to chill a glass and I
was like oh smart but now I see you
don't know anything I think is the only
one that's not red it's like a green red
sauce when you get a burrito I like it's
like the green sauce I like titties
outside of the box also I when I was
shaking this I got it everywhere and
then I did instead of pouring it through
the holes
I opened the top and just poured all the
ice out with happen so that's good
that's good
you want that I like ice in a drink LLL
drink I'm like Isaac from the [ __ ]
Love Boat in terms of ingredients we
have some ginger beer which I got
because you used it again for whatever
reason there's gin and then there's
Bacardi Oh No
and I didn't know about I forgot I saw
you with the triple second there I was
like oh dick i purrs a funny name and
then I forgot about it and then I didn't
put that in there I was putting
grenadine in it was excited until that
you until you said you makes gin and rum
yeah but you know what I mean come on
pine needles in 1718 time try it
it's finally time ryuuji so that was it
just ginger beer and ice oh and I
squeeze an orange in there I squeeze an
orange over there real real good like
real good and I'd beat the crap out of
it look at that thing
it still doesn't smell as strong as
Chris's but I think it's gotta be way
stronger I don't think so it's come on
was mainly sugar gonna be refreshing
please tell me I means I think I know
the amazing call up the dirty pews it's
strong it's stronger but at the same
time I damn it I don't like I don't mind
I don't mind the mixture of what rum the
rum and the in the gin doesn't actually
bother me okay I'm not trying that you
mean you're not a fan no I could pound
that it doesn't matter that's not good
that looks like lemonade right it's good
try it
flavor-wise it was good yeah yeah it's a
real good wine back here and mine is a I
did a similar I did a I did the Absolut
Vodka there's triple sec there is
cranberry a lime inside of it and a
little bit of ginger beer I added that
as a little bit of a that sounds good
well you get to judge your own drink I'm
gonna take a sip of it I think I usually
make pretty good ones I'm gonna sit and
this is you this is you not knowing of
how to make a Cosmo right yeah yeah I
know how to open a beer and pour shot
it's tasty it's a little too sweet I
liked it though
pretty sure I'm wrong on the ingredients
no you're right no I think you got the
ingredients right man ginger beer -
ginger beer is actually from the two of
you were tending bar and all I was
drinking with Kosmos I'd probably try to
get to her is better but if I got yours
I'd be like yeah whatever that
flavor-wise heather was the best one
let's find out what those ingredients
were
I've been combining three parts so uh
just a touch by the 2008 Lu what no JC
she beats you but by a nose that's what
I hear I think today we got a new double
double win by the ingredients and the
flavor Heather Pasternak everybody
taking care of him he in our bartender
all right that's it that's our show
thanks so much for coming by and
watching you guys get intoxicated and
eat shitty food oh wait we bought you
guys that uh hello Pasternak is my
handle Heather Pasternak calm is my
website I'm on Twitter at jo-ann HUC
cage on Huck I'm on Instagram Jo and
underscore HEC Kay and my website is
John Huck da and e and we're both on
drugs you can find me and John our honey
honeymoon fund is at cuck cariah's and
Huck makes names yeah we'll do better
next time guys ad impaired show on
Instagram atwitter yep check us out bye
guys it's 2 p.m.
[Laughter]
[Music]